[Music]
thank you for joining us you have a
great weekend
you too that does it for us be sure to
tune in to the CBS Evening News tonight
as we leave you let's take a look back
at all that mattered this week home
after home after home like this is
burned beyond recognition these
neighborhoods were just incinerated this
house is gone the flames got in the
attic and up it went fact that you got
out your family out yeah that's the part
that counts my kids are saying a
potential health crisis is one thing
that give the governor of Puerto Rico
pause we just need a lot of water it's
really hard to find outside analysts
questions whether these tax cuts will
generate economic growth you'd better
get it passed
[Music]
the key question now is whether hotel
security knew about an active shooter
before pattex deadly rampage we want to
draw the most accurate picture we can
the weinstein company is promising a
full investigation there are 13 women
free at them or alleging mistakes
typically I've ever seen we are in the
process of understanding the scope and
the span of what appears to have
happened instagram's now in the business
of street art working with other people
to in to inspire their street art
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
your world in 90 seconds your world in
90 seconds nobody says it like that
have you checked out Charlie's Instagram
account lately he is on fire there's
like this picture of him reporting from
the White House like he's like so hot
kind of just walking yeah yeah yeah he
likes it
you just get a touch out of this because
I thought hello gorgeous this is a thing
of beauty what you did on this chocolate
Copenhagen this is Denmark's capital
can't wait to dig into this Danish funny
thing is what we call it Danish is
actually Austrian why do you love coffee
so much home from Afghanistan an 11 year
old Donna Butterfield jumped into the
school workers arms after learning she
and her two siblings would be adopted by
her foster parents I don't know why the
guy just walking by he doesn't seem so
the mascot catch fans smiling Khaz Modan
cougar can Cosmo the Cougar teach my
Zumba dance class yeah you go to Zumba
dance class
no but maybe I'll start him puppies is
up
I could see in this serve I was in
trouble hey good whoa this is like
things about Gayle King I did not know
after all these years I'm so mysterious
[Laughter]
wait a minute good table in my office
come over I didn't know you had things
on day one your office yeah come on over
into CMS kitchen
[Laughter]
[Music]